alex you're muted
apparently okay sorry we can hear you
now
i found out how to run you thanks uh am
i sharing
am i screen sharing yes okay thanks okay
thanks for having me and thank you all
for coming
so i will be talking about corruption
robust reinforcement learning
it's been joint work with the doris
lucarious mark sim celebration once soon
so i'll start with a sort of a
subjective prelude so it's been a bit of
a
trend lately uh
to take some insights and some
extensions and ultron bandits and try to
accomplish
similar things in the in reinforcement
learning which you know
usually requires some new ideas so
i found myself doing a bit of that
lately
along some themes that i've been pushing
for
uh in the bandit land so one such team
was global constraints where
there was a bunch of work on dynamic
pricing with limited supply and more
generally on
venus with knapsacks and we recently did
something along that
theme in rl another theme was incentives
where you
want to incentivize sort of
self-interested agents to explore when
each one of them
selfishly would refer to exploit
and like recently we've been thinking
about like incentivizing reinforcement
learning
i also want to give a shout out to some
nice work under lipschitz assumptions
where one thing you would
you want to do is discretize the space
and sort of gradually zoom in
on the more interesting regions on that
space and like
i've been thinking about that in venice
for a long time and recently
uh my colleagues did a lot of that
in rl which is very tricky and very cool
uh so the theme on this talk
is uh what happens if the
environment is not quite a d
but also not quite adversarial so if
it's like you know
neither of these two extremes but what
if the reality is somewhere in between
okay so uh one
nice way of making this more
precise is this adversarial corruption
model where the adversary
is allowed to corrupt a few rounds so
there was a flurry of activity on that
in bandits
starting from a paper by tadouris
and this talk is about you know a
railway with adversarial car
options uh by the way uh tsodorius is
gonna give
a one hour one talk on this work in a
few days in a
virtual rl theory seminar so let me
advertise that it's it's gonna have more
details
all right so let me set up a model so we
consider
a standard model of reinforcement
learning called
episode ukrl so it's like we have a
fixed mtp where we know the state space
and detection space
but the rewards and
transition probabilities are not known
to the algorithm
we have k episodes of h steps each so
like the time horizon is effectively k
times h
steps uh so in each episode we
sort of run the mtp so that
the algorithm commits to a policy and
executes this
policy in the mdp for age steps and
observes the trajectory of state action
reward travels
so policies generally map histories to
actions could be randomized
we assume banded feedback in other words
the algorithm does not observe what
would have happened
if we were in a different state or if
the algorithm
chose a different action so that's like
a standard model we are interested in
regret
defined in a sort of standard way
in particular one can obtain regret that
scales is like
root of number of states and number of
actions
and the time horizon and it's known to
be optimal
uh by the way the dependence on
age the number of steps in an episode is
like
usually of a sort of a secondary
importance in this work
so we will you know just leave it at a
polynomial and kind of
not try to optimize beyond that okay so
that's the standard tiny positive correl
now uh adversarial corruptions come in
in a sort of easy way is just
before each episode an adversary can
come in
and corrupt it in an arbitrary way now
the
number of corrupted episodes with
you know is not known in advance we
don't know what to see throughout
and the goal is to scale
you know nicely in terms of c and
approximately be the approximately match
the
state of word for the case without
corruptions
okay so uh what can we do
oh yeah and it's important that c is not
known in advance
so what can we do uh the main result is
that
essentially we match the optimal regret
bound
times the c the the number of corrupted
episodes
and again it's not known in advance uh
by the way uh tabular just means that
we don't make any structural assumptions
and
we just you know obtain the great bonds
in terms of this as amc
so in particular the
adversary is allowed to corrupt
transition probabilities and as it
happens
it's the first non-trivial guarantee for
rl
with non-iid transitions and this is
like
one way in which like a rel land is much
more difficult than the bandit land is
that like in the vented land
you know adversarial cases you know is
essentially solved and
has been sold for a long time and in
ireland land is kind of open
so so this happens to be the first
non-trivial
guarantee for rl with non-iid
transitions
and like if you go beyond the bandit
feedback
so you know uh then it's sort of
the first computationally efficient
guarantee in any feedback mode
we also achieve a result for the linear
version which is kind of
another standard version of rl where
essentially
expected rewards and transition
probabilities are linear
in in the future vectors so
here the main point is that this number
of states could be
very large or even infinite and
you know we don't depend on on it
at all so uh we
we match the optimal dependence on t the
time horizon and the state of our
dependence on
d the damage uh even for the iad case
moreover we have we sort of have a
general transformation which takes
an algorithm for the iad environment
and makes it robust to corruption so
we have the improvable grantees for
tabular
and like linear variants which are
essentially the only two variants of
episodic rl
when people know how to prove things
but in principle we expect
you know we expect to obtain like
provable grantees for any variant when
we
know how to analyze uh optimism under
uncertainty in the iad model
uh also i mean we could
you know instantiate an algorithm even
if we cannot prove anything
so in particular our algorithm is sort
of
can be instantiated in this in a
concrete and meaningful
way for a deep rl uh
but of course we cannot prove anything
so okay a good time to talk a bit about
prior work
so the way i think about it there are
two stories
one from bandits and one from episodic
carell that converge
nicely to this project so the bandit
story
is about like stochastic versus
adversarial so
there were these classic papers that
solved you know either version
separately about two decades ago then
uh rebecca and i came along and kind of
obtained the best of both worlds which
is like this one algorithm which
achieves approximately optimal regret
for either environment without knowing
which environment you're
in and like uh there's been some
activity on like
improving and refining these bounds then
it was natural to ask
about intermediate regimes i mean what
if the world is
like neither is like really nice you
know nor
really bad but somewhere in between
a stochastic and adversarial and
one you know nice way of thinking about
it was
adversarial corruptions so that work i
started with the
liquorice miraculous by islamic paper
and their regret bonds were sort of
improved and refined
in two subsequent papers and there were
extensions
in like several other directions in
bandits
so okay the story in the episodic corel
is a little
different so uh there has been a lot of
activity on the stochastic version over
the past decade and like you know i
cannot possibly excite all of it
uh in particular we now have worst case
optimal regret rates and we have
instance dependent regret rates
and there has been some sort of active
line of work on adversarial rewards but
you know adversarial version is sort of
active but
you know far from
being well understood there is a lot
more to be done there
okay in particular let me
talk about two specific ideas that are
from prior work that are very relevant
to
this project it's it's kind of two
standard way to
two standard well-known ways to resolve
uncertainty one is
active sets and another optimism so
active sets is
basically we uh look at the data
we compile the set of actions that could
still possibly be optimal given the
current data we call it active set
and we choose uniformly or near
uniformly from that set
so optimism is that like i'm kind of
informally defining it we
pick alternative we pick an alternative
with the best
optimistic estimate which means like the
most
favorable estimate which is still
consistent with the data
so active sets stuff it works for
bandits and in fact it works for
corruption robust
bandits in the sense that it you know
this idea underlies the corruption
robust algorithm
in licorice miracle by islamic paper
but it fails miserably for reinforcement
learning
so in fact we can prove that like you
know
any reasonable way you could define
active sets
it's gonna suck and like if you choose
uniformly from them
you will suffer a very high regret
okay optimism on the other hand it works
really nicely for rl
uh in particular like
sort of a standard and natural way of
doing optimism in rl is something called
optimistic value iteration it works
great and
it sort of underlies uh
most of episodic real algorithms in the
literature and you know it works
great but it fails for corruptions uh
even for bandits and sort of easy to see
i mean
uh think about like an adversary that
you know comes in
and assigns a reward of zero every time
the algorithm tries to pick the arm that
is actually the best arm
then if if you do it log t times then
the you would fool the algorithm into
thinking it's a very bad arm
so anyway the point is that here you
have
two techniques so active sets works
great and the bandit land fails for rl
i mean works well for corruptions fails
for rl
and optimism works great for rl but
fails for corruptions
so okay in the rest of the talk i'll
sort of quickly go over the main ideas
so the starting idea is
sort of merry optimistic value iteration
with active sets and i'll
explain that kind of quickly kind of
one by one so value iteration is just
a very
standard well-known way to compute the
best
policy in the in the known mdp using
dynamic programming so you sort of
iterate from like last episode to the
first episode and you keep like
updating q function and view function
and the policy
so that's like very standard then
optimistic value iteration is that well
you don't
know the words and transition
probabilities so instead you
plug in like optimistic estimates
of the rewards and this way you have
optimistic estimates of the queues and
so forth
okay what we do is
we compute not only upper confidence
bounds but
lower confidence bounds on the q
function using
pessimistic reward estimates and then we
use that
to essentially compute to like recompute
active sets
and then when we uh
update update the policy we
restrict what we do to the active sets
so
this is kind of like the base algorithm
and what we do
and then we also need to use sort of
both local data which is like
data from this algorithm and like global
data and like
i will explain what that is in the next
slide and we use sort of
both data sets to compute ucbs and lcbs
so anyway that's like on a high level
the base algorithm and what we do
so the full algorithm is a sort of a
system of these base learners where each
base learner runs a separate instance of
the base algorithm
and it is robust against a given level
of corruption
which kind of scales exponentially so
like local data is like data assigned to
this
base learner and we also have like
global data which is a union of
data from like old all base learners and
we do need global data essentially
because of the trajectory mismatches i
mean different base learners
may traverse different trajectories in
the
in the state space so we start with the
you know least robust you know like
really non-robust base
learner and then at each step of each
episode we
randomly switched we may randomly switch
to a more robust
basel runner and you know we use sort of
a carefully chosen but data independent
uh probabilities for the switches and
the point is to ensure that we have a
sufficient probability
like at any step we have a sufficient
probability of switching to a more
robust
base learner for the rest of the episode
that's sort of the key point
in the algorithm and um you know the
data inside the given episode is
assigned to the
last and the most robust base learner
that we went to in this episode
so the high-level idea here is that
more robust based learners in some sense
supervise
the less robust baseline runners through
this global data which is
shared among everybody
okay so it's a
hundred page long paper and i have
exactly one slide to summarize the
analysis so i'll just go over
some key ideas so i mean we have a
general framework to
analyze these base learners with active
sets and
in particular like
you know base learners could do
something which is
not ucb selection or not quite ucb
selection and the point is like
how to analyze that uh
so we look at belmont errors which is
essentially you know the error inherent
in the bellman update
it's like a standard thing i won't go
into that
uh the point here is that like we have a
regret decomposition where we express
regret in terms of some expression
in terms of the bellman errors and this
allows us to plug in
a sort of analysis from the prior work
in a nice way so the
key issue is that okay we have
something which is nice maybe
but we only really know how to bound
regret for
ucb policies because like essentially
ucb policies give us sufficient
exploration
so somehow we need to compare whatever
we do
to whatever ucb policy does
so here's the way we think about it
uh okay we say okay what if we start
with
like whatever we do and then we switch
to a
ucb policy after some given step h
so let's call it policy
pipeline okay uh now
let's look at the occupancy measures of
these two policies after some
future step tau well
now let's compare these two occupancy
measures so
let's look at the maximal ratio of these
two occupancy measures where the max is
taking over
everything you know over this age and
over this
tau and over states and over actions so
it's like
you know how much can possibly
policy by star be different from the
the original policy pie in other ways
you look at it as like a change of
measure where like
want to change you know one occupancy
measure with the other measure
and like we pay a penalty and we're
trying to like overbound that penalty
so that is some code the key
quantity in the analysis this is at this
ratio
so anyway uh that's all i
want to say about analysis and like
teduris is gonna
give more details in the longer talk
i do want to take a step back and
point out that there is something going
on which which
is perhaps more general than corruption
robustness
namely we have this a real challenge
uh how to inject enough exploration into
some you know some
complex behavior for example behavior
that ensures corruption robustness
so optimism under uncertainty happens to
be the best hammer that we got
and we have this general design
principle that we randomly switch to
like a more reliable version of the
optimistic behavior
for example to a more robust base
learner
and we have a general framework for
analyzing you know
these algorithms uh in fact as a simple
proof of concept we provide a new
algorithm for the stochastic episodic rl
that is
kind of the standard version without
corruptions
that where we start with active sets and
you and uniform exploration and we
inject a little optimism to ensure
enough exploration and we obtain optimal
regret so
it's not a new result it's just a proof
of concept
the point is that this machinery i mean
we apply this machinery to corruption
robustness but
it could potentially be applicable to
other domains
uh okay so let me conclude with some
extensions and open questions
so we also have results for
instance dependent regret which is kind
of
similar to instance dependent regret for
bandits and that will have like
logarithmic regret as long as
some notion of a gap is small for like
you know appropriately defined notion of
a gap
so uh in particular we
match the state alert for the iad case
for the constant level of corruption
uh now the main open question is about
the dependence on c
on the on the number of corrupted
episodes
so in our work it is linear
and well can we make it better
and there are sort of several ways to
like ask this question so one is like
can we make it like
linearly linear but additive rather than
like linear and multiplicative
or can we obtain a non-trivial grantees
for c
greater than root c or you know can we
obtain like
sub linear dependence on c you know
ideally like root of c
and like one way to make our lives
easier here which may
help is that like what if we only count
regret for non-corrupted rounds
so the answer to all these questions is
like
yes independent land so maybe one could
do
some of that in the url and maybe not
okay so that's about it and let me
remind you guys again that uh you know
i come to that there is a stock and
there is a link to the paper
so thank you very much
all right thank you alex um we have
a few minutes before the next speaker
needs to start so
if anyone would like to ask any
questions and that would be a good time
do i understand that there is no lower
bond
at all for this corruption framework or
are there any load upon
so um like
no lower bound is specific to arl
give her bennett uh there is something
for
bandits but it's like it is subtle and
tricky so and like i may be messing it
up
one thing that i remember is
uh that like if you want
like better than log squared t regret
in the stochastic case
then you're doomed to like linear
dependence on the corruption
uh but there was a subtlety which i
don't remember oh oh uh i think that
also required high probability guarantee
is not expected guarantees
and there is a subtlety that i usually
get wrong
like like like
sorry okay let's leave it at that
uh right
ask a question oh going on
oh absolutely there is a root stereos
out but
if i remember correctly and i may be
messing it up slightly
it's for pure regret and it assumes that
like you don't count regret for the
non-corrupted rounds
but you know if i'm messing it up then
like you know
correct me in the chat
can i ask a quick question yeah so for
the
the linear mdp case uh are you paying
for the number of actions
oh yeah so that's one way in which we
are not
matching the state of war right that was
you know
yes hold on let me come back to it uh
so yeah so right so we pay for the
number
so we pay for the number of actions but
not for the number of states
so right and do you think this is
like fundamental somehow because i think
you can do
action elimination for linear bandits
without paying
so i mean i mean without corruptions you
can get rid of it
uh it's like we don't know how to do it
uh with corruptions i
i don't know i don't have an opinion on
whether it's fundamental
okay thanks i don't know just we cannot
do it
max i think you had a question or you
raised your hand no oh that was that was
an accident
sorry oh no it is um
okay well uh i actually had one
question as well what exactly is the
corruption model you're using
right so oh oh so the
right so the the adversary
in the beginning of each episode the
adversary can decide
whether to corrupt this episode and you
know
if it corrupts this episode it can do it
in an arbitrary way it could corrupt
you know rewards or transitions in an
arbitrary way
and we only count the total number of
corrupted episodes
i see and there's like numbers excuse me
there's no bound on the side of the
correction they could be arbitrarily
large or
is it the cost say still listen to the
bandit so we don't know in advance how
large it is and you know we uh
pay for that in regret so in a
particular
you know that bound is vacuous if c is
greater than routine
and and you know not vicus otherwise
so yeah thank you
maybe we have time for one more quick
question if anyone has something
uh okay let me
stop sharing uh
oh so tedoris raised a q a maybe chaba
already read it
but he's talking about the lower bounds
so he says square root c for pseudo
regret is achievable
for pseudo regret for the corrupted
objective this is in zimmer and zeldin
c is necessary if you want less than log
squared t for high probability for the
corrupted objective this is in
likhorous morocco named lemay and c is
necessary for the uncorrupted objective
thanks to doris yeah thank you
well in that case okay great day i see
you've already started presenting
uh please welcome our next speaker
daniel rousseau is assistant professor
at columbia business school
he is